oh my God I can't believe my results oh
man they got dirty what I personally do
BuzzFeed quizzes all day I do too this
is wonderful hi I'm Kate McKinnon hi I'm
Margot Robbie I'm America Ferreira I'm
Michael Sarah and we are the cast from
The Bobby movie and today we are talking
about BuzzFeed to see which character we
really are
[Music]
first what's the quality you look for in
a friend kindness loyalty sense of
adventure empathy creativity or sense of
humor Choose Wisely should we say what
we're choosing or is it pick a movie to
watch with all your best friends wait oh
my God you're like 10. well you're so
ahead oh sorry are we saying them a lot
loud or are we supposed to be doing it
together we're going to do this game in
Thailand they're just going to watch us
because uh you know we're trying to
entertain the masses should I say the
next are we talking about our animals
I've chosen Sensations
although I chose empathy yeah that is
ultimately in a friend important not in
a friend
without empathy yeah I was going to do
sense of adventure but I actually think
someone being funny is more important I
chose empathy he's good but then what if
what if they're not funny at all
you might have nose but sometimes people
are funny but exhaustingly yeah but
sense of humor can be just like a
different kind of human like a quick
Wick listen it's not that I don't want a
Sensitivity I just feel like to each his
own okay that's the point pick a color
to paint your dream house bubble gum
pink seafoam green sunset orange
electric Violet robin's egg blue or
Bumblebee yellow seafoam green electric
Violet I'm gonna have to go robin's egg
blue oh my gosh we all went no one went
Bumble what kind of blue is a robin's
egg what kind this this blue the blue is
showing you
it's a very beautiful blue robin's egg
blue it's very vibrant I'm changing I'm
going to that as well to Robin's egg so
ironic because you're wearing bumblebee
yellow no I thought stuff he's so
cliched was that the right usage of
ironic I bet not I use cliche room too
so
that one tonight's girls night
Bobby to co-host your slime
oh now this is just based on who we like
the looks looks
like a Barbie based on looks I'm going
with mermaid Barbie because I want her
to sing live
oh I see I see maybe lawyer Barbie in
case someone calls the cops I'm going
with Dr Barbie because I need some stuff
checked out
Barbie because I just feel like No One's
Gonna pick you picture because you feel
bad for her no I'm gonna go mermaid
Barbie because I don't feel bad and I
love mermaids I'm sure Emma would love
that I picked you Emma because I feel
bad for you yeah I almost I was like
Diplomat Bobby I see the Merit because
if you're having a party someone
diplomatic to keep everyone happy
good but I'm still going mermaid Sarah
and now pick a movie to watch with all
your best friends oh so many good ones
these are good so you can bring it on
because I've memorized the film and I
like to quote the dialogue along with
the movie I'm also
yeah I can't believe we haven't done
this before
they'll spend the rest of the sleep over
learning the dances which I also did all
through school I'm gonna say Wizard of
Oz but I don't want to give a reason why
okay choose a song to belt out a karaoke
to be loved lizzo bad guy Billy eilish
Closer To Fine the Indigo Girls late
night talking by Harry Styles cuff it by
Beyonce levitating Dua Lipa I'm going
closer to find yeah I gotta go with you
on that I'm gonna go cuff it Beyonce I
mean I want to dance to that
I'm not going to pick the anthem of my
people I'm going to say bad guy by
billiana bad guy
choose the inspiration for another
iconic toy themed movie American Girl
dolls Tonka trucks Cabbage Patch Kids
Beanie Babies
Webkinz I don't know that is barrel of
monkeys oh I know that one they made a
movie about well the beanie babies
aren't in it it's about the people who
made Beanie Babies oh really yeah
Elizabeth Banks love her the phenomenon
of the Beanie the phenomenon of the
Beanie Baby I'm gonna have to check that
out I've gone with American Girl dolls
because the SNL sketch lately oh no I
just I had them you know and um man they
got dirty those got dirty quick like the
producer in me wants to go with Tonka
trucks because I know that would make a
lot of money but I'm gonna go barrel of
monkeys because that's gonna be a weird
movie I'm going I'm going barrel of
monkeys too I would for myself I would
go Cabbage Patch because I had a Cabbage
Patch growing up that I still have
handed down to my son oh that's cute but
I'm gonna go Tonka trucks because my son
is crazy about trucks and all things
construction we finally choose something
from Barbie Mattel headquarters Barbie's
cowgirl outfit real world Barbie's giant
blowout party weird Barbie's weird house
the Ken War
weird Barbie's weird house I'm going to
Ken wool oh
what I've gone with Mattel headquarters
because I bet they have quiche oh my God
I got my result I can't believe my
results oh I'm Ken
I'm Barbie so am I I'm Ellen
you're so Alan yes that tracks why am I
Ken oh but look you it tells you why
we're Barbie do we have the same we're
the same your personality matches Barbie
your kind supportive and beautiful
inside out that tracks for you like
Barbie you like to see the good
optimistic side of things and always
want the best for the people you love
you want to say the last thing you
brighten
every single room you walk into and
people absolutely adore you
sit right now
pathetic friend this is how I feel
what house I would be in and like it's
happening to me I think this is how you
win this game look I've learned to
embrace the fact that I'm actually
puffer puff but I didn't think I would
be Hufflepuff I'm proud of it now but at
least do not slush well that would have
been cooler that would have been like oh
dark and edgy Margo why are you Ken okay
so I'm Ken apparently your personality
matches Ken you're passionate motivated
and just a little bit goofy like Ken
you're still figuring out who you are in
this big wide world but just know your
friends will always have your back
sometimes you might be a little lost in
life but just remember you are Ken and
Ken is you no I'm not at all wow
I don't know I think it tracks
again I'm sure you can get it a
different answer
I didn't pick Tonka trucks I did the
barrel of monkey
yeah is it yeah
right now I'm being such a cancer go on
why are you Alan you're loyal supportive
and brave like Alan you don't demand too
much attention just here for the good
times and the memories people might
underestimate you sometimes but time and
again you've proven you're truly a force
to be reckoned with Wow and it looks
like Michael is wearing eyeliner in this
picture and that's can't be accurate no
um
beautiful
thank you that was great I would thank
you but I'm mad so I that's incredible I
mean when I saw barbie I was like that's
pretty good
[Music]